hello folks and welcome back to another
episode nay the episode that best
summarizes what my hosting ability has
done to rotten tomatoes disaster of
course some of us have come to call it
the freak show
yep today we're doing a disastrous deep
dive into the flicks that warn us about
the future make us panic in the present
and most of all make us say wow it sucks
to be those people disaster movies have
been a staple of popular cinema for
decades and finally we get to settle the
age-old debate which type of disaster
movies are truly the best or the worst i
used to think like you dear viewer what
do you mean type of disaster movie bad
stuff happens that's it they're all the
same but believing that would make one
more short-sighted than the sniveling
weasel secretary of state and
independence day
captain get him out of here our expert
team here in the tomato patch has
arrived at four different sub genres
within the realm of disaster movies so
it's going to be weather flicks versus
space movies versus man-made mistakes
versus wild card motion pictures and
before you send that angry tweet when i
say man-made i'm referring to human-made
disasters uh this was a real good idea
so why didn't i just say that instead
well let's be honest most of these
horrific events are the fault of dudes
we're just not that good at smart you're
really starting to make us look bad so
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
iconic characters round four most
disastrous and then we'll do a wild card
round that has absolutely no relation
whatsoever to the wild card disaster
subphylum it's just a coincidence you
know like when a boat hits an iceberg or
it's the apocalypse or an asteroid is
true on its way to earth or a raging
twister throws a cow at you that last
one really hurt me personally because
it's the movie that broke up the second
incarnation of van halen okay got that
one out of the way early buckle your
seat belts kids because there is no
tomorrow and the day after tomorrow
you might want to wear some mittens
let's get it on
round one box office for a variety of
reasons disaster movies have been
anything but that at the box office it's
likely similar to why we love going to
see horror flicks or suspenseful
thrillers opening weekend audiences love
catching a cinematic event that
hopefully showcases a much more tragic
and entertaining fate than our own i
don't know about you but
i intend to
write a strongly worded letter to the
white star flying about all this
it also helps us game plan how to avoid
such a future in our own lives and
communities but above all else it's fun
to watch stuff blow up on the biggest
screen imaginable of the 16 motion
pictures being showcased today only five
grossed below 100 million dollars
domestically and volcano and contagion
got oh so close in fact it was a
disaster movie that owned the title of
all-time box office king for a cool
decade
[Music]
fortunately most of the other films
we're going to talk about today are not
based on a true story like titanic
unfortunately celane dion wasn't asked
to do the soundtrack for any of these
other flicks unless you count beauty and
the beast as a disaster movie which if
your bell you might given the legality
of marrying a beast in certain states
what did you say titanic counts as a
man-made disaster movie and it joins
forces with other big time people
falters like the towering inferno and
the day after tomorrow if only that fire
broke out on the day after tomorrow
could have you know warmed things up a
little bit but then we just breathe in
whatever gwyneth paltrow and a million
other poor souls did in contagion
those are the four human caused movies
and they combine to make a hefty perflic
average of
544 million dollars per movie obviously
led by titanic's 1.2 billion domestic
take my wallet will go on and she was
what mother called new money you know
what else we'll go on fun space
adventures where we get our asses kicked
for most of the movie it's so much more
fun to be losing for two hours when will
smith jeff goldblum and company are
there to keep us entertained
i could have been at a barbecue
independence day headlines the space
disaster movies faction and that 1996
super hits mega box office dollars can
only be attributed to president bill
pullman's rousing speech
today
we celebrate our independence day
cloverfield had some laughs but took
itself more seriously war of the worlds
took itself super seriously and
armageddon has no idea what the word
serious means because it dropped out of
school after kindergarten space
we're just in the beginning part of
space we haven't even gotten to outer
space yet still bruce ben and eris miss
saving the planet did just shy of 400
million dollars and the space movies
make up for a healthy competition to the
man-made movies as they average 367
million dollar per flick
whether heavy disaster films also came
to play and stormed their way into the
field with the quintessential disaster
film that saw the light of day the same
year as id4
1996's twister tornadoed its way to
buffo numbers and 2012 borrowed an id4
director to gross over 200 million
dollars on its own san andreas and
volcano bring up the rear but still do
enough to get weather oopsies an average
of 242 million dollars per flick it's
been a good game thus far but it appears
that man-made mishaps are gonna take the
round but wait what's that
good god that's wild cards music the
wild card team could be anything there's
the insanely fun crocodile movie crawl
oh wait they're alligators or they're
both crawl has lots of scary swamp
dinosaurs and if it's water you like we
can fill up that brita filter with
underwater another surprise good time
movie starring kristen stewart you fan
of good times then let's party with the
only straight comedy in this episode
2013's this is the end then we also have
the wave which i'm told is about a giant
wave
i'm sorry not a wave the wave it's gonna
be a fun bracket busting category i'm
sure but sadly only this is the end
across the 100 million dollar mark at
the box office
which means two things it has no shot of
scoring a point in this round and we as
a nation failed crawl it was so damn
entertaining angry thicket aqua lizards
come on america
space movies did a hell of a job
adjudicating itself in this round but
numbers don't lie and neither do giant
sail barges titanic helps steam man-made
mistakes to a win here and it's sort of
poetic that we have a 70s throwback in
the towering inferno a generational love
story with titanic and a super cold
futuristic doom harbinger in the day
after tomorrow all getting us on board
together plus contagion which
inexplicably shot way up the charts at
the start of the pandemic
really y'all watch crawl instead
anyway human cause disasters get the win
in round one and they go up one to
nothing winning that ticket rose was the
best thing that ever happened to me
round two tomato meter slash audience
score speaking of the team that won
round one
man am i interested to see how this one
plays out big time disaster movies like
armageddon tend to not do well with
critics although titanic certainly did
as a matter of fact the only thing those
two movies do have in common is that
they were recently featured on rotten
tomatoes is wrong available wherever you
enjoy podcasts and my friend justine
mourinho saw both of those movies an
average of 15 times each in the theater
she's a very funny comedian and
apparently fandango user of the century
okay fun's over mark back to work
armageddon soundtrack was
aerodynamically designed to shoot to the
top of the billboard charts however the
film itself experienced the opposite
fate on the tomato meter
oh makes you feel good doesn't it
yeah it's the low mark of any disaster
film in competition today supporting
just 38
but don't worry astronaut ice cream
enthusiasts every other space movie is
fresh yes even independence day is ripe
at 67 percent and both cloverfield and
war of the worlds are in the 70s at 75
and 78 percent respectively that put
some respect on space's name and that
faction averages out to a fresh 64.5
percent
weather um
wouldn't be so lucky we had a parade
planned but raining on it is the fact
that none of our fritz colemans are
fresh
he's a tv weather person and so i think
i'm just going to keep doing that joke
is that funny
2012 is so happy armageddon exists
because without that movie in 1998 this
2012 movie would have been the low bar
at 39 percent volcano and san andreas
gave a good showing but are also rotten
at 49
each and twister twister pulls the
spaceballs in that it's as close as you
can get to fresh and should be fresh
we'll talk about it on the podcast at 59
what did we not throw enough cows at you
it's got bill paxton and helen hunt for
crying out loud the tomato meter isn't
mad about weather films as they average
just 49
after round one i'm very nervous to put
wild card motion pictures back in the
game i just don't want them to come in
last again
oh and they're fresh
holy crap they're all fresh except
underwater at 47 but let's not drown the
lead the three other wild card flicks
are above 80 percent this is the end of
the wave are at 83 percent and crawl is
only 16 short of where it belongs
currently at 84
so that makes wild cards the bread
winner average of
74.25 percent
hang on to that quarter my wildlings
because here comes a huge boat man-made
accidents are once again competitive
thanks to titanic's 89 and contagions 85
those are actually the two highest
tomato meter digits for all of our
bittersweet 16 talkies the towering
inferno slips a little bit but remains
fresh with 69
but here comes the day after tomorrow
peeing in the snow at 45 percent damn it
gyllenhaal that takes man-made movies
down to a 72 percent average which means
wild card flicks are in the lead okay
audience score now the spotlight is on
you and if you didn't reward that flying
bovine twister is once again robbed of a
fresh rating ah this time at 58 percent
folks just do not care about willard
scott's this is not good
they only average
47.25 on the audience metric and that
makes them the only team not fresh
independence day and armageddon shuttle
space movies just past titanic and the
towering inferno's man-made squad with
an average of 64.25
to 63.25
the door is open for wild cards and here
comes the kraka gators crawling through
crawl is tied with id4 for the highest
audience score of all films here with 75
and the wild things crew is the only
outfit to boast all four movies being
fresh with the audience it's average of
68 percent and that earns them a
definitive victory in round two it's
people one wilds one space zero and
weather zero with a wind chill of minus
nine dallas reigns would have found that
funny oh that's good
that was good round three iconic
characters let's be honest we go to see
these movies for the destruction nothing
detaches the velcro from my wallet
faster than a giant movie poster with
tornadoes or aliens or fire or alago
crocodiles but as enjoyable as that
stuff can be and we'll see just how fun
in the next round more often than not we
leave the theater swept up in the
emotion generated by characters and
relationships we didn't expect to care
about it all i went into titanic ready
to root against kate and basketball
diaries i walked out saying the
unthinkable
f that billy zane you will honor me
you will honor me the way a wife is
required to honor her husband jack and
rose are certainly worthy of iconic
status they saw each other naked under
the guise of art danced the night away
and managed to get a car so steamy that
herbie the love bug needed coolant we
all knew it was going to be an epic
disaster film we had no idea it would be
the characters that kept us coming back
for more
for some people 20 times more justine
but it's arguable the titanic doesn't
even have the best cast in its own
division that's right if it's man-made
disasters you want how about dudes dudes
like paul newman steve mcqueen and fred
astaire in the towering inferno faye
dunaway is great in there too lots of
famous folks similarly appear in
contagion and the day after tomorrow but
the connections aren't as memorable
unless there's a fire or a band playing
as the ship sinks into the ocean i will
give a nod to lawrence fishburne and
contagion though because he's a doctor
and his first name you guessed it ellis
way to play for our team larry can i
call you larry
no
thank you lawrence will they won't they
couple seem to play well in disaster
fair which is one of the reasons that
twister is such a hoot bill paxton and
helen hunt were clearly made for each
other even if that means they'll get a
divorce and then remarry each other and
then divorce and then rinse and repeat
every decade plus twister gives us
classic rock aficionado food played by
the incomparable philip seymour hoffman
and kerry elways is a baddie you root
against but don't hate quite as much as
say billy zane and titanic
there's nothing i'd deny you
if you would not deny me
after all at least carrie was in the
princess bride however al roker might be
disappointed in this round because the
only thing i might champion in a
disaster movie more than a sweet couple
is a solid father-daughter dance no
armageddon wait your turn
okay
i'm talking about barry pepper and kaya
scodelario in crawl you genuinely care
about them both and kyle's hailey
character gets major bonus points
because she's battling some gators and
guess where she swims in college
florida their mascot the gators get it
take a backseat tim tebow we got a new
star athlete on campus the wild card
bracket also scores some major points
with the bevy of celebrities lampooning
themselves like seth rogen jonah hill
and the scene stealing michael sarah
everybody listen up listen
who took my
cell phone man craig robinson might get
the good guy mvp in this sub genre but
in order to compete with man-made
disaster flicks in this round we're
gonna have to do some space trucking all
i have to say is
as in the will smith variety not ric
flair independence day could have gotten
away with stock boring performers and
still done a boatload of business off
the premise alone but like titanic we
kept coming back for more because of
will smith's brave pilot jeff goldblum's
nerdy cable repair man bill pullman
saying anything and randy quaid doing
anything even those with less screen
time like viviga a fox mary mcdonald and
harry connick jr make the most of their
scenes oh and we have robert loggia
first rule of math it's always addition
if it involves logia any of these
categories would have loved to have had
a cast that presents as many different
dynamics as independence day we get
bromance with will harry and jeff will
we get devoted couples like bill mary
vivica will father son with judd hirsch
jeff and the loose cannon with randy and
whatever randy was drinking and aliens
that use netscape navigator space
feature films already have a good
argument with just one movie so let's
pile on war of the worlds as a much more
serious but still heartstring tugging
feels generated by tom cruise's dad to
dakota fanning's daughter character
while those aliens were turning humanity
into angel hair pasta cloverfield was
showcasing a genuinely cool new monster
with some biting humor but to get a win
in this round space movies needs one
more knockout punch and with sincere
apologies to anyone watching this with
the last name gruber
here comes bruce willis him and his oil
drilling crew treated that giant
asteroid no better than john mclean
handled hans and simon and in the
process they won our hearts you want a
father-daughter tearjerker armageddon
has it with tyler watching her dad pull
a switcheroo to sacrifice himself so she
can date ben affleck until he meets j-lo
still gives me the feels all these many
years later the entire crew in
armageddon is just so damn likable and
chock full of star power owen wilson
michael clark duncan steve buscemi
william fitcher peter storm mayor and
the always reliable will patton and
that's the fellas on the rock back home
we saddle billy bob thornton with most
of the ridiculous dialogue but he spins
it like a champ he literally had to talk
audiences into believing oil drillers
would do this mission better than actual
astronauts and
we bought it that asteroid is the size
of texas and so is the public's affinity
for armageddon and yes i'm also counting
the bad boys from boston as characters
in that movie if twister broke up van
halen
again armageddon might have kept
aerosmith together to this very day
are they cool with the drummer again
from that vegas thing all right maybe
i'll have to have the id4 aliens ask
jeeves that question on the world wide
web humans accidentally wrecking shot
movies gave us a good fight in this
round but it's the humans we love for
wrecking aliens and asteroids that get
the win
oh boys
i'm back
space movies wins the round and get on
the board
okay weather movies time to put up or
shut up okay it's gonna be okay round
four most disastrous yeah so the
characters are cool and all but you know
what's even better than seeing a huge
movie star like the rock how about the
rock saving the world from an earthquake
and no he didn't just say the west coast
just ask paul giamatti as he terrifiedly
removes his glasses this round is all
about destruction which sequences truly
give us the most thrills chills and
induce more thank heavens for watching
this movie and not in it wild card
destruction gets on the board early
thanks to a ginormous underwater
explosion in the accurately titled film
underwater we also have a giant monster
that adds to the fun speaking of water
did also mention the crawl has a
hurricane in it so yeah we get some cool
big picture destruction but it's those
close quarter moments of tension that
score the biggest in the paul hogan
legacy movie the wave conjures serious
emotions with its tsunami as we've seen
real life ones wreak havoc on coastlines
and lead the news for weeks the last
couple of decades you cannot count out
wild carters in this round as they also
have that little apocalypse thing going
for it this is the end has tons of
laughs but that earth opening sequence
at the climax of the film is no joke
weather flicks need a big score here and
boy do they get it 2012 has an
apocalyptic level feel to it because we
get everything mother nature could
possibly toss at us giant waves
earthquakes floods dogs and cats living
together and given that it's directed by
roland demaric we get to see all of it
in its glorious end of the world
technicolor greatness the relationships
in that movie are
but wow is it a sight to watch the earth
rebel against the limo drivers san
andreas stars the aforementioned dwayne
johnson as a hella rescue hero who flies
all up and down wine country witnessing
the biggest quake in recorded history
california really gets its comeuppance
in this specific phylum of disaster
because the geological event known as
volcano spews hot lava all over us
good-looking 9-0-2-1 owers but whether
movies don't just beat up hollywood the
midwest gets a few more punches courtesy
of the twisters in
what was the name of that oh right
twister and yonder bond's direction puts
us right in the eye of the storm
alongside dorothy we pivot to space
movies to even the score on the east
coast cloverfield makes sure that no
exotic dance clubs will ever exist again
in times square meanwhile both
independence day and war of the worlds
take pride in leveling equal opportunity
uppercuts all across the globe id4 has
such a ball in blowing up virtually
every man-made structure in the world
and war of the worlds gives us a much
more in-depth look at how aliens might
treat us when we meet them
it's um
not good e.t was a lot but for all the
love armageddon got in the iconic
character round it's not going to be as
much of a force here simply because the
whole point of the movie is to avoid the
disaster in the first place now we do
get lots of meteorite carnage and a crap
ton of shrapnel hitting our planet so
thanks again to harry stamper and the
gang for successfully avoiding
humanity's permanent vacation dude fault
movies have been a threat in each and
every round thus far and while flicks
like contagion certainly feature
destruction it's not on the epic fun
scale of a weather or space movie it's
just a lot of famous people coughing
really really bad the towering inferno
pioneered large-scale effects with the
torching of the san francisco high-rise
and titanic honored the legacy of those
we lost by having the boat in the movie
sink in real time accurate with how fast
it actually went down back in 1912. the
day after tomorrow is the team mvp here
as the storms didn't sue wipe out most
of our towns cities
and 7-elevens but there's something so
pure about the spectacle of earth's own
ecosystem hitting the reset button now
when you or i want to recharge we take a
nap mama nature conjures a storm quake
or wave so powerful that it can fail
billions of regular folks and a handful
of celebrities in the process the
independence day aliens gave a charles
barkley-like effort in this round but
they ran into the michael jordan of
destruction 2012. did i really just
compare michael jordan to that movie
all this madness mayhem has gone to my
head sorry mike don't take it personally
uh he already did the weather channel
takes the round and as you'll see here
we have a front coming in that ties the
ball game it's one to one to one
to one holy sh do you do you guys
realize what this means and now it's
time for the wild card round awards
awards really no no no i'm kidding it's
best of the best time we've seen every
faction score one point but in true
bracket style only one movie can emerge
from each division in a winner-take-all
brawl that will determine the match
after much deliberation and yes napping
i've arrived at the following champions
representing weather will be twister
battling on behalf of man-made oopsies
titanic the space representative will be
arm
independence day independence day it's
gonna be independence day and crawling
through the wild card genre will be
come on did you expect anything
different it's crawl baby and then
crocodator is gonna have a rough outing
here they make for some fun villains and
serious tension throughout the movie but
overall crawl just can't match the epic
scale and heartfelt emotion of its
blockbuster competition twister can as
it has some real firepower in terms of
stars engrossing plot emotional
bandwidth and lots of wind what i enjoy
about this flake is that these brave
humans being are seeking out the
disaster in order to learn more about it
they're not reacting to some imposing
threat as much as they are trying to
figure out how to best prepare and
defend us against these tornadoes the
love triangle of paxton hunt elways and
the ragtag group of supporting players
along for the ride adds a believable
captivating human element to the story
that reaches levels we don't normally
get in disaster movie fair but the
emotions ratchet to an all-time high
with titanic because it has so many
different ways to get us invested jack
is an underdog from the get-go and we
just want the poor guy to get on the
boat before it takes off once there the
audience puts our knowledge of history
aside in favor of a cavalcade of new and
engrossing folks to either root for or
against and by the time the massive
destruction begins we marry our fondness
for jack and rose with our sadness at a
fate sealed at sea and it all leads to
kleenex stocks soaring was the room on
the route for jack probably but that's
not the point he sacrificed himself to
ensure rose's heart would go on
and they probably would have broken up
within
what six weeks on the mainland let's be
real you are rude and uncouth and
presumptuous and i am leaving now
independence day should feel satisfied
just by defeating armageddon to get to
this point but if you've seen id4 you
know that flick has a tone of
invincibility when it comes to sheer
bang for your popcorn buck who cares
about logic and science and plausibility
when we can have this much fun instead
painstaking detail went into remaking a
barge to look exactly like the titanic
and twister feels like you're joyriding
along with real tornado watchers
independence day employs a different
strategy its goal is to make the
audience feel like they can join in the
fight and win the day against an
imposing alien presence we all have a
fun friend like will smith's captain
hillard they're just not a fighter pilot
we all know a tech junkie they're just
not experts in alien communication and
we all know a randy quaid
many many randy quaids we probably have
met the real one at some point we all
feel like we could even become the
president of the united states who by
the way in this movie yeah it's also a
fighter pilot
other champion disaster movies happen to
have unexpected rewards like we care
about a relationship or we get to see
special effects or god forbid we even
learn something real about science but
independence day works the best as a
disaster movie for the simple reason
that it's more than a motion picture
it's a whole amusement park with one
thrilling ride after another the laughs
the chills the thrills never let up and
in the end we get people to care about
and co-effects and real science
uh well it was the first time i heard
triangulate used in a sentence so i
think that counts as learning the best
disaster movies give us a good time even
as we're witnessing cinematic tragedies
unfold on the biggest scale imaginable
to have aliens attack and nukes go off
and billions of death is easy to have us
all witness that walk out of the theater
with a giant smile on our face and say i
want to ride that again
that takes craft it's a tough call
between id4 and titanic titanic had the
guts to kill off a main character but
independence day
save the dog and for that and all the
other hoots and hollers that's given us
ever since it wins the round and gets
team space disaster movies the win in
today's episode no no no
i mean after this is over could i like
get a hug from you or something and for
jack and rose stance or tornado
aficionados are all you
well i think it is just alligators and
crawl you probably think that my
decision to crown space movies to champ
here is a disaster
you are so annoying but here's the
beauty of that now it is your turn
you call your shot and let us know which
disaster movie style fits you the best
do you prefer epic shipwrecks at sea
hungry swamp creatures towering infernos
or john cusack dodging most of that
stuff in a very unmaneuverable car hit
me up on social media with your take at
mark ellis live and let us hear or know
at rotten tomatoes where you stand
or where you stood until that giant
meteorite hit you i'm mark ellis i will
not stay awake just to hear you
breathing because
it's kind of creepy until next time be
safe humans and all you
extraterrestrials watching
welcome to earth
you